let's go to our next caller 202 area
code caller from 202 go ahead
hey David this is Nabeel calling from
Boston actually not too far for you guys
I was wondering if you caught the ben
shapiro appearance on Real Time with
Bill Maher I think it was Friday no I
didn't what have what happened uh well
you know it was usual the usual
prepubescent sophistry from ben shapiro
you mentioned one thing which i wanted
to get your opinion on that was i think
bill maher asked him what are you gonna
do in 2020 and he said it depends but he
said he thinks most of the damage the
social fabric that Trump has done has
already been done and he really can't do
much more the day Missouri there so he
actually used you know deploying this
his argument for why he still might go
for Trump despite Trump's awfulness I
think he's doing it as a way to avoid
saying how he pretty much aligned with
all of comes policies and doesn't wanna
you know doesn't want to admit it but
what do you think about that was it just
a complete excuse or you think there's
some element of truth to that there's
two possibilities right one is the one
you bring up which is ben shapiro has
been tepid about trump but in reality he
loves Trump's policies and he wants to
figure out a way to sort of say hey
doesn't really matter if the guy wins
again because the damage has been done
and it's it's hiding his support for
Trump there's another view which is that
Shapiro is disgusted with Trump but he
wants to not alienate a lot of his
right-wing audience which loves Trump so
in so he's he's doing it he's sort of
playing coy for that reason I honestly
have no idea it's been like two years
since I've emailed with Ben Shapiro at
all and I've never spoke I have no idea
what his sincere views are about Trump I
think you know somebody like Dave Rubin
might be well-positioned to tell you
because I know that they've been hanging
out a lot but I have no idea what's
going on in Ben Shapiro's mind well
that's not definitely a good thing
better for it but my question isn't so
much about the Ben Shapiro angle of it
it's more about what he actually said
you think there's any truth to what you
said no no I think that there is untold
damage that Trump could do in the future
I think listen we've only marginally
avoided Trump invading multiple kind
we found out as we're gonna talk about
on the show today that he was way into
invading Venezuela getting out of the
Iran deal could be a precursor to going
in there if the North Korea deal goes
south we may be looking at invading
North Korea it's been the Russia
commingling that has probably kept him
from doing more in Syria so I think that
there is an insane amount of damage that
Trump could do and that's just talking
outside the US never mind inside the US
so I don't agree whatsoever with the
assertion yeah completely agree thank
you so much all right very much
appreciate the call from Nabil in the
Boston area always good surprised me
because it wasn't from a Boston area
code